- Hi, it's Rie.
Today, a friend will be challenging me
to take a popular food and Make It Fancy.
Today's guest is Andrew!
- Rie, I wanna challenge
you to make eggnog fancy.
In the winter, a warm cup of eggnog
is one of the best things to have.
I've always wondered what are other ways
that I could enjoy this drink.
So I wanna see you make eggnog fancy
and see what you come up with.
- Eggnog.
I've never had eggnog before.
Very controversial drink.
It seems like this one is non-alcoholic,
but typically served with alcohol.
It's yellow.
(playful music)
Oh, it's very sweet.
Milkshake almost, but with egg.
I prefer milkshake.
(Producer and Rie laugh)
It's so creamy.
The spice definitely have a
like holiday Christmas feeling to it.
I think flavor-wise it's good.
It's just, I don't wanna
drink this (laughs).
I've got some great idea
and I'm excited to Make It Fancy.
(playful music)
All right, here's what I got.
Heavy cream, butter, cream cheese, eggs.
From the pantry, I got flour, brown sugar,
meringue powder, gelatin
powder, condensed milk,
salt, vanilla extract, nutmeg, allspice,
cinnamon, powdered sugar,
lemon, baking powder,
sprinkles, food coloring and spiced rum.
All right, let's get started.
Make It Fancy.
So first, our room temperature butter.
I have two stick and a half.
One cup of brown sugar.
Mix them together using stand mixer.
I'm going to mix until light and fluffy
and color is a little bit lighter.
Add egg yolk one by one.
Make sure each yolk's well incorporated
and scrape the side.
Okay, so all the eggs are incorporated
so I'm going to add quarter cup of eggnog.
If you don't have stand mixer,
you can use hand mixer
or you can use whisk,
but it will take longer.
We are using spiced rum.
I think it's gonna be a nice additional
adult holiday flavor.
And I'm adding one tablespoon.
- [Producer] George Washington
had his own eggnog recipe.
- Ooh!
- [Producer] And it had rye
whiskey, rum and sherry.
- He's the original triple alcohol.
Yeah, back then, they
didn't have internet,
but they had alcohol.
I'm going to make my flour mixture.
Pinch of allspice.
Half teaspoon of cinnamon.
Quarter teaspoon of salt.
One teaspoon of baking powder.
Grate nutmeg, about half a teaspoon.
Grated my finger.
And lightly mix.
I'm gonna add half.
(mixer whirs)
Rest of that.
You want to mix until
you won't see any visible flour bits.
Transfer this dough into a plastic.
Wrap it tight and rest this
dough in a refrigerator
about two hours.
Two hours later.
Remove plastic.
From this dough, I'm going
to measure 10 ounces.
Between two parchment paper,
I'm adding dough and start rolling.
Still cold so it's a
little bit tough to roll,
but gradually soften up.
So you want to roll out about
one-eighth inch thickness
and about 11-inch diameter
and I'm going to line this dough.
Use your finger, line into the tart mold.
Using rolling pin and
roll over couple times
and it will naturally fold like a magic.
We are going to dock this dough.
So when you dock this, it doesn't puffs up
and it doesn't shrink.
I'm going to put this in
the freezer for 20 minutes.
Bake at 450 for five minutes,
then lower the temperature to 350
and bake another 15 minutes.
I have rest of the dough right here
and I'm going to roll same way.
This dough is still a little bit tough
so you can kind of tap it
and make it easier to roll.
Just take off the top parchment paper.
I'm using star-shaped cookie cutter
and dust with flour.
Making star-shaped cookie
and you're gonna line
in your parchment paper.
You kinda wanna push
from behind and mold it.
I'm going to unmold this
and bake 350 for 10 minutes.
Quarter cup of eggnog,
quarter cup of heavy cream,
quarter cup of brown sugar,
one tablespoon of butter.
Mix it until well combined.
Bring it to a boil
and cook about five minutes.
Mix occasionally.
- [Producer] Back in the 1800s,
eggnog was used to treat diseases.
- Was there alcohol in it?
I cook about five minutes
and it's kind of bubbly
and it look thicker
and I'm gonna start whisking
constantly from this point
'cause you don't want mixture to be burnt
and I'm going to cook
about two more minutes.
It smells good.
This looks done.
It's very thick.
Pour this into a heat-safe glass bowl.
Set this aside to cool in room temperature
and moving on to the next step.
One tablespoon of water
and sprinkle one and
half teaspoon of gelatin.
Let it bloom about five minutes.
While I'm waiting, mix cream cheese
with hand mixer until fluffy.
Seven ounces of condensed milk
and once it's well mixed,
add in half cup of eggnog,
one tablespoon of lemon juice.
(hand mixer whirs)
then adding half teaspoon
of vanilla extract,
quarter teaspoon of cinnamon powder,
about one-eighth teaspoon of nutmeg.
Blend well.
(hand mixer whirs)
One tablespoon of hot
water to bloom the gelatin.
Make sure it's all melted in hot water.
Gelatin into the mixture and mix well.
Strain this mixture so I can
make sure this is smooth.
Okay, mixture is ready but
I have more things to do.
My tart shell is baked and cool,
and I transfer my mixture into pitcher
so I can easily pour.
And this is the eggnog
butterscotch I made.
Pour this mixture.
You don't want to overfill it.
Give a nice drop of butterscotch.
Using skewers and kind
of makes nice pattern.
Just a freeform.
Pattern looks pretty and
I'm going to chill this
in a refrigerator about six hours.
Four cup of powdered sugar,
quarter cup of meringue
powder, and mix well.
Add water.
Start with four tablespoon first
and adding more water
until desired consistency.
So I added meringue powder.
It's faster to set if you add it,
but if you don't have meringue powder,
you can just add egg whites
or corn syrup and water,
but it will take longer to set.
This is a good consistency.
It's ready like this because
I'm going to pipe it.
Divide into three bowls
and I'm adding one with
green food coloring
and this one is red.
I'm gonna add this to a piping bag.
Green, white.
My eggnog cookies are baked and cooled.
Now I'm going to decorate
with icing and sprinkles.
It's just a freestyle.
You want to kinda draw the outline
and kinda fill the space.
And while it's still wet,
I'm gonna just put some
red and white sprinkles.
So it's kind of cool if
you put like big sprinkles.
Kind of look like Rudolph.
Put the green sprinkle.
So this one I'm going to decorate,
look like a snowflake.
This is probably my favorite pattern.
Okay, holiday cookies looks very festive
but we are not done yet.
A cup of heavy cream,
two tablespoon of eggnog,
quarter cup of powdered sugar,
half teaspoon of nutmeg.
I'm gonna use immersion blender.
Mix it until stiff thick.
Spiced rum, one tablespoon.
I usually use whisk but I
think this is a cool trick.
Transfer this into a piping bag.
We're gonna use it later.
This is the tart I was
resting in the refrigerator.
It's set now and I'm going to decorate.
Using star tip and piping straight.
If you want to make bigger star,
just press and hold it and make it bigger,
and if you want to make it smaller stars,
you can just lightly squeeze.
I'm placing bigger cookies first
and small cookies around it
so it kinda look like a Milky Way
and filling with eggnog cream in the gap.
And we are done!
(light string music)
Holiday eggnog tart.
Very festive!
(cheerful music)
I have a Christmas gift for you.
- Really.
- Yeah.
- Oh, a hat.
I was like, it's this cake, right.
Thank you.
- A fancy cap.
- He has a big head.
- Made eggnog fancy as
you challenged me and--
- This does look so fancy.
Is that what this is, butterscotch,
this little flower design?
That's the kind of
thing where I look at it
and I'm like, I will never make desserts
as well as whoever made this.
Is this a face?
Is this like a person?
- It was inspired by Rudolph.
- So is there booze in this tart?
- Yes, always.
- I mean, look at that!
- You always have a very particular way
of inspecting (laughs).
- I like to get it onto my same elevation
and I also like to really smell something.
- Cheers
- Cheers.
This is a treat.
- Thank you.
- This is like what I
dream of when I think of
a holiday treat.
- All right, Andrew, do you
remember what we do after?
- Yeah, you do like some
John Travolta disco.
(Rie laughs)
- [Producer] He had his
own version, actually.
- Did I?
- You are John Travolta.
Three, two, one.
Make It Fancy.
- Make it Fancy.
(cheerful music)